en 1897 le célèbre auteur mark twain a
eu à démentir la nouvelle de sa propre
mort alors nous sommes en 1897 à new
york à une époque où les journaux
abondent et l'yonne forte concurrence
entre les différents médias qui va
vendre le plus de titres âge et ce sont
les hommes souvent qui attire les
acheteurs
mark twain qui est très célèbre à
l'époque de son vrai nom samuel clemons
est pour le moment en angleterre il est
l'auteur des romans tom sawyer et
huckleberry finn le new york herald
s'intéresse à son histoire parce qu'il a
eu vent que l'auteur serait gravement
malade probablement mourant qu'il a
perdu toute sa fortune et qu'en plus ce
serait en train de perdre ses facultés
mentales vicky renault mais pour son
côté presets éric brac twain se trouve à
ce moment là en angleterre parce que
doit couvrir le jubilé de la reine
victoria
pour le new york john hall concurrents
du new york herald
lorsqu'on lui annonce qu'un journal a
annoncé sa mort prochaine
bien entendu on voulait avoir la
réaction à chaud de mark twain mark
twain réagi en disant waouh c'est une
exagération
on voit ici le côté un peu ridicule de
la chose puisqu'il est bel et bien
vivant alors le new john holmes va faire
un article intitulé mark twain music
alors mark twain et amusé de l' annonce
de sa mort prochaine
il annonce qu'il est bien en vie qu'il
est tout à fait en santé et que si les
finances vont désormais très très bien
en utilisant le nom de mark twain pour
pouvoir vendre des journaux en
l'associant plus à une fausse rumeur une
fausse nouvelle
on vient de donner naissance à ce qui
sera bientôt le journal à potins